what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime outpro and man these
absolutely insane bakugo theories have
gone too far the mha fandom has
absolutely lost its mind since the
apparent death of bakugo in the manga
and people are desperately trying to
come up with some way of explaining how
he could survive from bakugou traveling
back in time to become the second one
for all user to him unlocking a hidden
Quirk or to Arie using rewind to send
bakugou back in time so that he can
become deku's Dad okay I made that last
one up but when I posted it as a joke on
Twitter at anime Emperor a bunch of
people actually believe that that is how
crazy things have gotten in the fandom
that said spoiler alert I am almost
certain that bakugou will survive and
I'm about to explain how he will be
brought back to life so let's get into
it you guys know the drill leave a quick
like and comment right now if you like
our videos and you want to see more in
the future and of course if you're new
here or maybe you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe Vibe yet remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell is a really important
and completely free way of directly
supporting the channel if you don't go
through the steps of subscribing hitting
the bell and then selecting the option
that says all you are still gonna miss a
ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed unfortunately that is how
YouTube works that said I really do
appreciate every single one of you who
does bother to leave a like and to
subscribe okay so like I said despite
all these crazy theories about bakugou
potentially being resurrected or
traveling back in time or becoming
deku's dad the truth is that the latest
chapter of the story may have already
revealed how bakugou will be brought
back to life it was subtle but it was
right there for all to see the latest
chapter started with a desperate genist
standing over bakugou's lifeless body
genus confirms that bakugou has no pulse
and that his heart has been ripped to
shreds he's not breathing he has no
pulse blood is not being pumped through
his body and he is therefore clinically
dead so yeah at this point in time
bakugou is technically dead he died the
heroes and hero students on the UA
Battlefield are devastated by this
Revelation Meteo is shocked and Furious
aizawa and monoma are devastated and
genus himself is in disbelief meanwhile
shiganaki is posing like a JoJo's
character and gloating about how
disappointing the heroes are he also
asks who's next which hero will become
the next present that the villain is
going to leave for Deku when he finally
does arrive on the battlefield miruko is
absolutely Furious that she didn't take
shigaraki out before his procedure had
been completed back in jakku and even
now she is desperately fighting against
him in fact she is actually biting
through his finger mutations proving
once again that she is an absolutely
Fierce and unyielding fighter and one of
the most badass waifus of all time and
as shigaraki continues to tell the
heroes about how screwed they are the
chapter shifts Focus to kamino where
Dobby is back from the dead but before I
get into the rest of the chapter and all
the crazy bakugo theories let me direct
your attention back to that page where
shigaraki is posing like cars from
JoJo's if you look at the panel of genus
in the bottom left corner you will see
that he is pointing his hands downward
and activating his Quirk fiber master
and since we know that genus is
currently standing over bakugo we can
deduce what is about to happen bakugou's
heart has been ripped and damaged so
genus is about to use his Mastery over
fibers to literally sow bakugou's heart
back together then the heroes will find
some way to shock his heart back to life
either using an electricity Quirk or
nitroglycerin or something along those
lines so yes bakugou really did die but
he will be resuscitated by genus and the
other Heroes I am almost certain that he
will be brought back to life and when
this is eventually confirmed in the next
chapter or a few chapters from now don't
forget to come back to this video and
drop a comment now whether this turn of
events will be considered a cop-out by
the fans is another matter altogether
but to me it seems clear that this is
the way that the story is headed I will
discuss more possibilities for what
happens to bakwa next at the end of this
video but first let's talk about Dobby
and the return of all for one in his
prime So speaking of fake out deaths and
defeats Dobby is back for round two
despite the fact that Shoto was
officially declared to be the winner of
their fight several chapters ago after
incinerating some of endeavor's
Sidekicks and rip to those guys but the
only one I care about is Vernon Dobby
explains that he managed to copy shoto's
X on the chest move before Shoto buried
him in his icy Flames so that is why we
were seeing a little shiny spark on
Dobby's chest he was just activating
this move that he copied from Shoto in
order to counter shoto's attack Dobby
now looks like a flaming zombie nomu on
steroids but he is still alive and ready
to continue the fight and then we
learned that skeptic has apparently been
communicating with the major villains
this entire time and he tells Dobby that
endeavor is located at the ruins of the
gunga mountain Villa where he is
fighting all for one it seems that
skeptic was able to hack into some of
the major security and communication
systems that the heroes are relying on
and he seems to be in the process of
hacking the highly Advanced system that
the UA is currently using if I
understood this correctly it seems that
read industrial's old company detonarat
had a hand in creating many of these
systems that the heroes depend on and
since skeptic helped build these
networks and systems they can't keep him
out no matter how hard they try we then
get a glimpse of the civilian shelter
where many of the characters we know are
currently hiding including the rest of
shoto's family and those kids with
strong quirks that bakugo and Shoto had
to babysit in their makeup exam we also
see those two spies the guy who looks
like mob from Mob psycho and the girl
who is wearing a beanie they look like
they just received some important
information from skeptic and it seems
like they are about to do something we
don't know what exactly they've been
ordered to do but the implication here
is clear the civilians at the shelter
are now in danger the chapter ends at
the gunga Mountain Battlefield with all
for one now almost fully restored to his
physical prime all for one declares that
the villains are about to make their
dreams come true and the text on the
final page confirms that the villains
are about to go on the offensive
shigeraki still has the upper hand at UA
Dobby has now retaken the initiative in
kamino and all for one is presumably
about to become an even bigger threat
for endeavor Hawks and the others as his
original body is restored back to its
Peak Performance things are looking
pretty bad for the heroes at this point
in time but let's be real that will
change once again when Deku and possibly
other Heroes make their appearance in
the near future now back to our boy
bakugou who as I said is technically
dead right now but will almost certainly
be resuscitated and brought back to life
in the next few chapters I mentioned
already what I think is the most likely
scenario genus stitches his heart back
together then his heart is shocked back
to life and later on he will be healed
more thoroughly by some healing Quirk
and or by modern medical technology
bakugo is likely going to be injured and
weak for a time but he will survive and
bakugou's injured state will motivate
Deku to fight even harder against
shigaraki but there are other more
outlandish scenarios out there and those
are the ones that have been gaining a
lot of traction on social media we have
the theory that either Eddie or someone
else is going to use rewind to rewind
bakugou's body back to a state where he
wasn't so drastically injured then we
have the theory that bakugou is going to
be sent back in time possibly due to a
rewind related side effect and that he
will survive but he will be stuck in the
past eventually becoming the second one
for all user this means that he will
live but he will never see his friends
and loved ones again although his
Vestige is going to meet Deku many years
later and of course we have my personal
favorite Theory which is that bakugou is
sent back in time by Eddie and becomes
deku's father I am kidding of course but
it was actually a hilarious to see some
people believing that fake chapter
League that I posted on Twitter good
times what do you guys think am I right
in my belief that bakugou will be
resuscitated after genus sews his heart
back together do you think that a more
outlandish scenario involving something
like Aries Quirk is actually possible
did it surprise you to see how crazy the
fandom got with all the theories in a
desperate attempt to find some way for
bakugou to survive oh and if and when
bakugou does end up being resuscitated
as I predicted will you be okay with
that or do you think that would be a
cop-out by horikoshi I know a lot of
people hate the idea of an important
character like bakugo dying which is
totally understandable but when it
seemed like he really died there were a
lot of fans who praised horikoshi for
Having the courage to kill off such a
major character is that about to be
completely undone with bakugo's
resuscitation definitely leave your
feedback down below I always love
hearing from you guys but I especially
love seeing what you think in such
situations where the fandom is in panic
mode and wild theories are flooding
social media you know what to do if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like it
only takes you a second but it helps out
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications it might
seem like a little thing but it really
helps me out a lot here on YouTube you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
Opera patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
Alpha Sigma Pate hefa The Toasted Chi
Cory McGowan big Buddhist and Jeremy
pontier and I can't forget all of our
Pro Hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh on Hell Cruise Alicia
Octor fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivena and Anime s code M if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon or here through
YouTube memberships even a single dollar
helps and it means a lot to us as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys